garde si je puis me permettre avec toute
mon affection je pourrais être ta maman
en fait donc je vais parler comme si tu
étais ma fille tu vas bien sûr chine
donc en fait tu parle souvent de l'âge
20 ans j'ai jamais évoqué de j2 la
jeunesse si si bien sûr qu'ici hier tout
le temps ses revenus et ça revient tout
le temps sauf que quand on a 20 ans on a
le droit de vote et les gens qui ont 20
ans aujourd'hui ils ont voté aux
dernières élections présidentielles et
moi ça m'énerve un peu si tu veux que on
déresponsabilise et sous prétexte qu'on
est jeunes on peut écrire tout et
n'importe quoi est ce que je pense avec
a dit oui et je pense qu'il faut faire
de la pédagogie il faut apprendre il
faut dire il faut dire ce qui est bien
et ce qui est pas bien ensuite
deuxièmement tu as dis je me suis
renseigné alors c'est quoi tes élise
lucet de tpm p est ce que tu as fait
vraiment une enquête
enfin je veux dire est ce que ces clashs
investigations est ce que ces enquêtes
exclusives nom soit et des éléments
soient tap tap a des éléments mais c'est
trop grave si tu veux pour dire un truc
comme ça
et enfin troisième chose tu parle
beaucoup des réseaux sociaux et tu dis
oui mais les réseaux sociaux c'est
n'importe quoi enfin vraiment eu les
condamnés hier tu les a condamnés ces
réseaux sociaux mais tu es aussi une
créature des réseaux sociaux et bien sûr
voilà et donc je pense que jamais que
les réseaux sociaux c'est un truc c'est
que miss france en fait à se dit le plus
cool c'est gilbert d'agathe voulait lui
répond alors j'ai jamais condamné les
réseaux sociaux j'ai parlé de la
dangerosité que pouvait représenter un
hachage médiatique tout tout tout a été
enregistré tout est disponible en replay
donc j'invite je t'invite d'ailleurs
allé le regarder parce que j'ai jamais
le dit les risques avait fait mal comme
ça aussi c'est jamais jeudi les réseaux
sociaux c'est mal jamais dit sortez vos
enfants des réseaux sociaux et je n'ai
jamais parlé de l'âge ça a été un contre
argument utilisé par jean-luc que
j'entends absolument mais ce n'est
jamais sorti qu'il avait dit la première
fois en tout cas quand on a parlé de
cette affaire si si bien sûr et alors je
vais juste faire la karine le marchand
du pauvre parce que j'ai évidemment pas
son talent passion dans les salons les
coutumes à la même manière qu'elle a on
n'est pas dans le pré et la même manière
qu'elle a autopsié matthieu delormeau
moi c'est ce qui m'a paru finalement le
plus touchant chez toi c'est à dire que
de la même manière que gilles verdez
réclame la sortie de mes mails de ce
programme est bien pour les tweets que
tu as fait qu'ils étaient aussi abjecte
et ignoble effectivement on pourrait
dire pourquoi à bientôt pour est athée
pmp et je pense que c'est pas que ça
mais c'est pour ça que tu as été
déchirés au site web a mal vécu cette
situation là en tout cas moi je n'ai
ressenti comme ça
et quand tu quand tu me comparer à élise
lucet de tpm t toutes les digues avaient
enquêté à gaz le reste des analogies
tout à fait juste très vite ça va être
un peu chiant et je m'en excuse
auparavant en avance la fachosphère
c'est un groupuscule des mouvances
d'extrême droite sur l'espace digital
mais ce n'est pas ce n'est pas je suis
fâché au point fr ce n'est pas vivre les
fachos points comme ne sont des sites
d'informations extrêmement travaillé
extrêmement au plus
bien sûr et sans but est extrêmement
extrêmement camoufler et n'importe qui
qui ne soit absolument ni fachos ni
raciste ou quoi que ce soit peut se
faire avoir alors pourquoi y exprimer
son compte les a relayés pour quoi faire
c'est vrai